ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen sieg ja aber
warum ist es denn sie ist folge 50 das
ist jetzt nicht folge 100 oder folge
eins oder so dass wir jetzt die krasse
special wir sind ein paar meilen im
challenge tritt heute es ist richtig
dass heute folge 50 am start ist und ich
habe ja gesagt dass auch das heißt
vorbei also vielleicht bisschen ich weiß
es nicht das entscheiden wir dann wenn
es soweit ist die sache ist allerdings
dass sich das schaf ja extra deswegen
gedacht hat deswegen verändere ich heute
meine ganze die farbe das ist natürlich
kein cheating vor mir das wieder
irgendwer vorwirft ich habe extra für
euch hier was aufgenommen wie ich das
gemacht habe ich habe dem namensschild
genommen das ding auf chep umbenannt und
damit rechtzeitig auf scharf gemacht und
dadurch veränderte sie ganze zeit die
farbe rot mir die kommentare geschrieben
also danke euch auf jeden fall für den
tipp wir haben auf jeden fall für heute
nur fünf dinge zu tun die auf unser do
liste stehen denn die heutige folge so
ein bisschen kürzer werden denn die
letzten folgen man alle fast eine halbe
stunde lang oder noch länger
deswegen direkt erste sache die wir
heute zu erledigen haben ist dieser
wille gem
wie geht es überhaupt perfekt
die sache ist dass er hier oben immer
noch schild und ich möchte das
eigentlich nicht mehr deswegen würde ich
gehen hier einfach mal runter schicken
und da wurde mir geschrieben ich soll
die leiter abbauen so dass er dadurch
runtergeht perfekter hätte nicht gedacht
dass direkt klappt die sache ist halt
dass wir jetzt wieder ganz easy die
blogger einfach hier draufsetzen können
dann noch hier eben die fichtenholz
stufe und die beiden leitern können wir
hier wieder anbringen ist ja nämlich
fischer und da er hier dem blog nicht
mehr hat besucht er sich jetzt neuen
fass blockarbeit block wurde war dem
wird allerdings hier oben ich finden
deswegen wieder den wahrscheinlicher zum
kisten haus suchen oder jetzt und der
halt hier die ganze zeit rum das bringt
die ch2 macht eure arbeit das war auf
jeden fall die erste sache die wir für
heute vorhaben von den fünf teams die
wir vor auf dennis da haben die zweite
sagte sein arzt letzte folge denn wir
benötigen ja immer noch hühnchen für
unsere tiere insel dort ganz hinten
steht überhaupt noch ein bienchen bist
du nicht die tiere insel hinten steht
hat er ist schon schön aus das ist dass
honig da wohl irgendwie auch geschrieben
dass sie mit einer schere rechts sich
darauf machen kann dann krieg ich
honigwaben dann haben aber wiederum
andere geschrieben
wo kann man das besser nicht dann geht
auch ein billen lässt stock geht oder
vorneweg und das war mir eigentlich
nicht selber gern eigentlich ein zweites
was ich danach dahin auf die tier insel
machen kann
die sache ist allerdings dass wie
bereits gerade schon gesagt wir erstmal
die hühnchen holen müssen und dafür
nehme ich mir wir haben eigentlich genug
körner hier vorne am start deswegen wir
haben ja irgendwann dem wir haben die
irgendwann damals mal glaube ich rüber
gepackt hinten zu fahren auf der
villacher insel die sache ist allerdings
dass ich mich erstmal kurzem ein
bisschen schwingen werde denn wir müssen
nach der ganze kader mit einer lore
fahren
irgendwie laufe ich die wege nie richtig
lagen sowie lang laufen soll dann schon
spaßig ignoriert das hausdach
habe ich verfolge 100 habe ich das mir
vorgenommen das schwein stellt immer
noch nie vorne in der lore das ist
allerdings eigentlich ganz gut denn wir
brauchen auf jeden fall mehrere um die
wiener vermehren zu können also erstmal
die loren hier hinsetzen 242 münchen
das ist ja keine tiere brauchen sieht
man sie doch so küche im modernen dings
von hier wir müssen auch noch die mob
fallen ja noch ganz viel zu tun in
diesem projekt das allererste was mir
noch ein bisschen es allerdings erst mal
in münchen holen also deswegen eine ganz
ganz kurze tl für euch wie ich hühnchen
suche
[Musik]
so games für hühnchen gefunden einmal
hier eins und einmal hier vorne und die
haben wir sogar gerade schon einige drop
das heißt wir kriegen sogar ein drittes
hühnchen
ich bin hier wieder an der stelle so die
zuschauer werden sich erinnern wo ich
damals die kürbisse hier vorne irgendwo
gefunden habe und dann haben wir hier an
dieser herr braucht so ein bisschen hier
vorne weil dieser kleinen wasserfall
käse so heftig das ist das beste gefühl
der welt wenig kratzen die sonst auf
jeden fall untergegangen jetzt ist mein
auge hier von einem tränen ach du
scheiße ist aber auch egal denn ich habe
mir hier von einigen scharfen die hier
oben gelaufen sind ein bisschen wolle
geholt da könnte ich auch nochmal ganz
hinauf mein gott gegen sogar noch mehr
eier dann können wir die auch noch
mitnehmen hier ist an noch kohle die
nehmen wir auch nochmal direktmandat
können nämlich mit den village in so ein
bisschen handeln die sache ist
allerdings dass ihr heute wirklich nicht
prior haben soll und ich packe auch mal
ganz kurz wieder die fackeln in die
andere hand dann seht ihr hier ein
bisschen mehr hat denn wir sind ja wegen
der hühnchen hingefahren
deswegen habe ich mir auch im bettchen
gemacht damit ich putze nacht
überspringen kann und dann die hühner
sicher auf meine insel bringen kann von
daher sollte es jetzt glaube ich auch
möglich sein schlafen zu gehen
deswegen ganz speziell fackel in setzt
damit wenn ich ganz im dunkeln hier
schlafen und jetzt einfach hier in der
runde hinlegen das bett nehmen natürlich
selbstverständlich wieder mit so dass
wir nicht hier plötzlich dann irgendwie
wieder spawnen am nächsten tag die
werkbank nehmen wir auch mit und die
fackel können wir hier stehen lassen so
ein bisschen als erinnerung
beziehungsweise wir das doch das bett
jemals stehen um eine kleine erinnerung
hier vorne also ich nehme euch hier
vorne jetzt auf jeden fall mit so erst
auf dem weg zu mir ich hatte hier vorne
auf jeden fall noch ein zweites hündchen
gesehen ich weiß nicht oder es ist ob
das hier vorne hier vorne ist es auf
jeden fall
und jetzt noch mal ein ganz großes für
euch wie ich dir über bewege in die
loren und auf meine tier insel
[Musik]
so da ist jetzt auch das zweite hühnchen
rüber auf die andere insel gekommen das
büdchen hier schnell mal eben abbauen
mitnehmen und wahrscheinlich wieder
hinsetzen das ist ja auch gut wieder
wegkommen und jetzt locken wird das hier
mal ganz kurz auch noch auf die insel
das andere hühnchen hab ich hier vorne
am start hat sich bei den beiden chicken
nuggets die wir haben wollten sind auf
jeden fall da ich habe doch feiere ich
hoffe die mal hier hin vielleicht kommen
die hühnchen raus ist es nicht der fall
gewesen
das nächste um das wir uns kümmern
müssen ist eine situation die wir bei
der zauberinsel haben die sonne geht
schon wieder unter ich bin bei noch
nicht ganz so weit will man halben
stunde erst wir haben eine kleine
schwierige situation hinten an unserer
zauberinsel das ist mir aufgefallen als
ich dieses letzte video geguckt habe bzw
vorletztes video wo wir irgendwas
verzaubert haben da hinten
die sache ist nämlich dass er das wasser
nicht so ganz sein soll wie es ist nicht
so ganz ist wie es sein soll und dafür
benötigen wir erst mal einige eimer ich
weiß nicht wo ich die gelagert habe ich
habe die voll mit lava ich nicht ein
wenn er sollte aber auch erst mal
reichen
deswegen müssen wir das wasser ein
bisschen korrigieren ich hoffe mal ihr
seht euch was ich meine und ich hoffe
dass mich jemand da verhält ist weil das
wirklich sehr sehr pingelig ist und zwar
ist das hier nicht so hoch wie das ich
weiß es tut mir auch leid allerdings
möchte ich deswegen das hier so ein
bisschen auffüllen und das gleiche
problem haben wir auch hier vorne und
das gleiche problem haben wir auch hier
vorne und ich glaube auf der anderen
seite auch genau hier vorne und hier
vorne
da ist es noch so genau das hat mich ein
bisschen getriggert was wir allerdings
auch mal machen können ist unsere angel
ich bin lange dabei
wenn wir noch genug lappe wir haben
genug lapislazuli und ihr seht doch
unten dass ich 40 level habe und
deswegen möchte ich diese level nutzen
um meine angel zu verzaubern und mir
demnächst dann hoffentlich das reparatur
buch unglück des meeres und keine ahnung
was zu angeln die sache ist ja das ist
die sache und dass ich mich auch die
fünfte sache die ich für heute machen
möchte
aufgegangen bevor wir allerdings
schlafen gehen können wir hier im
baumhaus erstmal die ganzen truhen
abbauen das hätten wir eigentlich auch
für das klingst benutzen können für
unsere kleine klitsche kisten krippe die
sache ist allerdings dass die die hier
wirklich nicht mehr benötigen und jetzt
frage ich mich einfach was ich aus dem
baumhaus machen soll
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
geiler als unser haus da hinten weil wir
halt hierhin indirekt den geilen weg zum
montag das kann ich auch mal offen
machen hier vorne
wir sehen hier direkt den
sonnenuntergang und das ist echt extrem
geil was wir können direkt zu tieren
darüber schauen sind auch instant auf
der willicher insel wenn wir darüber
möchten
allerdings kann ich mir die kommentare
schreiben was wir aus dem baumhaus
machen sondern wir daraus irgendwie auch
was in die richtung weil sie nicht
tränke brauen machen sollen oder so
scheint es mir wie gesagt gehen und in
die kommentare danke auch übrigens noch
mal für euren riesigen support bei der
letzten folge waren einfach einen tag
lang platz eins im deutschen youtube
trends mega crazy ich muss erstmal items
hier ein bisschen sortieren so die items
sind sortiert der würde test erfordert
direkt am rhein gelaufen ich wollte mal
ganz kurz gucken was passiert wenn ich
die news schere sich magenta wolle und
jetzt kriege ich auch mal gerne ja da
ist mir leid ihr seht schon immer im
inventar ich habe drei [ __ ] am start
die werde ich mal ganz kurzes spiel
nicht mal meinen weg gelaufen
die wollte ich mal ganz kurz hinsetzen
so ein bisschen abstand das durch
bisschen besser aus was ich machen
wollte war erstmal hier vorne an unserer
todo wand etwas entfernen und zwar
scharf holen das haben nämlich am start
den bürgermeister und tier insel baum
insel blumeninsel für chicken nuggets
haben wir alles zusammen gemacht dort
hinten das haben wir auch erledigt was
wir auch erledigt haben ist freund für
schwein finden die sind jetzt mal nicht
hier auf der insel allerdings auf der
anderen insel weil ich will ja hier
nicht verschiedene wir haben hier immer
noch ganz ganz viele sachen die wir
machen müssen mit dem friedhof begraben
so bin ich mir nicht sicher
ich finde ich ganz schön dass es hier
ist und das ist auch historisch wertvoll
weil es halt aus der ersten folge oder
aus der zweiten oder dritten ist
deswegen will ich endlich keine grav
insel machen wir können allerdings mal
ganz kurz
[Musik]
was nun allerdings erst mal auf der to
do liste steht ist dass ich hier noch
eben die beiden sachen rein packe die
ich gerade nicht benötige
doch jetzt mich um etwas kümmern möchte
was ich euch in der letzten folge
gefragt habe denn hier vorne haben wir
jetzt ein bisschen platz hier haben wir
jetzt ein bisschen platz deswegen nehme
ich mal ganz kurz die fackel weg und
werde auch hier so ein bisschen sander
bauen jetzt gleich wahrscheinlich warum
luca den sand könnte doch nutzen als
untergrund für das gebäude was du dahin
machen wolltest mir der mann gebäude was
er im wasser sein soll
denn ich wohne unter anderem von einer
person geschrieben dass sich doch bitte
eine angel hütte bauen soll
ziehen wir so einen bootsanleger denn
unser stieg der dort hinten
stattgefunden hat bei der brücke
den gibt es ja nicht mehr richtig weil
wir dort die brücke zur insel hin gebaut
haben deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
baue hier vorne einfach eine widget
nehmen die ich würde job eine angel bzw
bootshütte hin und diese angel und
bootshütte soll so ein bisschen im
wasser stehen das finde ich ein bisschen
cooler und dann haben wir auch so ein
bisschen die kollektivität zum wasser
und zum ozean und da ich mich ein
bisschen konzentrieren wollte aber das
habe ich auch schon beim zaubern gesagt
und das hat mir auch nicht ganz
funktioniert ich habe auf jeden fall
bock wie ein paar kleine sachen zu
angeln die ich dann auch meine ganzen
werkzeuge rüstungsteile schwerter et
cetera verzaubern kann die sieht auch
schon das wasser hier gleich sich
automatisch aus das ist ganz geil jetzt
brauche ich allerdings erst mal vor du
sollst daraus die teilnehmer in meinen
bodenmann auch hier sagt das ist hat
mich das ding wir haben gar kein platt
roh wie die boote irgendwie hinlegen
können wenn man ganz kurz einsammeln ich
sage jetzt erst mal ganz kurz hier vorne
so dass ich ihn nicht um inventar
rumfliegen habe jetzt haben wir wieder
hier
ich gebe den schildkröten zwei minuten
bis sie wieder einer drin sitzt hier
vorne soll auf jeden fall die angel
hütte hinkommen und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht wenn dich das kannst du mich
auch so
[Musik]
so die sonne geht dort hinten runter ich
habe gerade 25 minuten lang diese sachen
hier zusammengebracht oder ist mir
aufgefallen dass mir noch nicht ganz
ganz ganz ganz große menge fichtenholz
kennt aber der beste stoff in minecraft
also aber war goldbarren fallen lassen
mein gott wisse mit den gott dann machen
wir spenden dass wir spenden das an den
ozean
[Musik]
apropos spenden meiner dicken freunde
ganz kurze sache die ich euch erzählen
kann bevor ich jetzt bzw während ich
rüber fahren zu den tieren soll denn
dort haben wir auch die ganze bäume
ich habe dass die masken aus meinem shop
luca - shopping.de vielleicht kann einer
von euch den slogan als alles anfing mit
corona ezb habe ich ja maske
rausgebracht und ich auch direkt zu
beginn gesagt ey wir produzieren die so
günstig wie es geht und die paar cent
die wir pro maske verdienen werde ich
auch spenden
das sind jetzt die 20.000 euro
tatsächlich zusammen geworden deswegen
haben wir uns gedacht dass wir die
massen jetzt mal rausnehmen und den
betrag spenden werden deswegen wenn ihr
der in welche ideen habt dann schreibt
vergehen und in die kommentare ich habe
auch letzte schon auf instagram gefragt
da kam nur aus flughafen könnte ist es
ja nicht selbst spenden irgendwie eine
schönheits op oder so dankeschön an der
stelle mega korrekte vorschläge auf
jeden fall aber man kann sogar spaß
beiseite ich möchte das geld komplett
spenden und zwar 50 prozent an eine
gemeinnützige organisation in köln und
die anderen 50 prozent an etwas in
hamburg und wenn ihr euch irgendwie
hamburg auskennen sagt einen bescheid in
köln habe ich schon eine
spendenorganisation im kopf die ich dort
kenne die das geld auf jeden fall gut
gebrauchen können wenn ich in hamburg
was einfällt schreibt auch gerne in die
kommentare dann spendet 10.000 euro an
was in köln und 10.000 euro an irgendwas
in hamburg ja ich
ich bin ganz ehrlich da das jetzt hier
alles schon wieder sehr sehr lange
dauert und ich nicht schon wieder eine
30 minuten folge machen möchte würde ich
euch noch mal ganz kurz einblenden die
ich hier ein bisschen bäume farbe bzw
einfach ihr ein bisschen mehr holz suche
denn das ist gespannt
[Musik]
ich traue mich gar nicht das
auszusprechen
aber wir müssen demnächst mal wieder in
die hölle ich hasse diesen ort über
alles und die sonne jedoch gratis
darunter ist wenn man das auch mal kurz
geklärt die sache ist dass wir keine
knochenmehl wir haben das nicht ganz
blätter wir haben keine wahl mehr
überhaupt heute überall schon geschlafen
auf der insel dann hier am wasser dann
da ganz sieht hinter als wir die münchen
geholt haben ich hab keinen knochen
immer mehr am start dementsprechend auch
keine knochen blöcke und kein knochen
dass er schon geil wenn er so einen
riesenbaum werne
naja vielleicht im nächsten unser holz
wird leider nicht ausreichen also diese
126 die wir hier haben die sache ist
allerdings dass ich euch jetzt einmal
ganz kurz zeigen werde wie ich generell
vorgehen möchte bei der ganzen situation
und zwar soll der weg hier untergehen
und eigentlich müsste der weg der für
drei blöcke breit sein
und leute 2 max hier egal
das kannst du dir vielleicht nicht
ausdenken das kannst du dir doch einfach
nicht ausdenken an verdammt noch mal
genau der gleichen stelle wo damals
schon mal so ein ding die luft geflogen
ist
es muss jedoch ganz kurz erst mal wieder
wahrzunehmen und das dem schaf zu
fressen geben damit er sich ein bisschen
beruhigt er wird von explosionen vor
nach hinten geschleudert also hier
kommen sagt frist ein bisschen was das
soll ja kam es hier neben hits hey das
ist doch alles der dorfcharakter die
erde mitgenommen und bin ich kurz stehen
geblieben weil ich gucken wollte ob ich
den weg ab hier schon drei blöcke breit
macht habe ich glaube ich mache den ab
hier dann also so warte ganz kurz ihr
die buch steinstufen hier den weg
einfach rechtsklick dann hier wieder
zack dann hier wieder das weg
rechtsklick das outback hier eine stufe
hin dass weg hier nochmal rechtsklick
und dann hier auch nochmal eine stufe
hin beziehungsweise diese drei kommen
generell an dem netzwerk aber das werdet
ihr wissen wenn ich das ding dann baue
allerdings macht es ihnen denn dieser
folge sondern in der nächsten folge ist
dass man hier hin und die werkbank die
ich hier habe die brauchen wir demnächst
auch noch die habe ich nämlich die
stehen ja ich finde das jetzt nicht so
schlimm dass der weg hier drei blöcke
breit ist und hier vorne nur zwei blöcke
das ist ja ganz gut unterteilt hier
vorne mit der situation ich noch dann
mache ich das hier sogar auch noch zum
weg und dass sie dann im nächsten auch
noch zum weg dann wird das hier auch so
eine kleine fläche wie hier vorne wir
haben hier auch seine laternen situation
das könnten wir dann eigentlich könnte
es auch hier machen aber dann haben wir
hier keinen weg drauf ist so geil wenn
man auf seinem weg dann was platzieren
könnte aber das funktioniert nicht so
richtig die sache ist allerdings hat
sich jetzt erst mal ganz kurz zeigen
werde wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
und zwar bauen wir hier vorne und hier
vorne erst mal die pfeiler hin die quasi
so ein bisschen zeigen hey hier geht's
jetzt quasi los mit dem fischhaus dann
gehen wir von hier eins zwei drei vier
fünf sechs blöcke nach ihr zeigt dann
hier vorne noch kein hin hier einen
drauf und hier einen drauf hat sich
fragt warum ich die hier alle aus
normalen reichen stammbesetzung dass sie
aus eichenholz liegt einfach daran weil
die hier diese eichenstämme die kosten
und einen weniger also wenn ich aus
vier von diesen eichenstämmen um daraus
ein eichenholz zu machen und dann
bekomme ich nur drei eichen macht jetzt
keinen sinn an alle die sich mit
bisschen auskennen wissen was ich meine
so sparen wir ein bisschen ressourcen
und ein bisschen holz hier wieder sechs
stück zur seite und die jetzt hier unten
nämlich ein hochziehen ich habe
eigentlich genug holz wenn ich das hier
alles wieder so machen würde wie bei der
zauberinsel hinten
da es allerdings die sache dass wir ja
bei der zauberinsel das problem an das
ist immer so ein bisschen flow die war
die ganze zeit das hat mich immer so ein
bisschen getriggert deswegen machen wir
es hier so und die teile sollen auch
alle im boden perfekt verankert sein
jetzt 123 hier wieder zur seite und von
hier ein ding hochziehen zack zack zack
so dann können wir darauf hier eine hoch
und hier noch ein hin und dann hier
wieder fünf zur seite also 1 2 3 4 5 und
dann hier unten ein hochziehen hier wird
dafür brauchen jetzt eine menge
erreichen
aber ich mein lieber wirklich einmal
richtig machen und dann wissen wir okay
das ist alles verankert kompakt reihen
der partie ich bin hier wieder unter
wasser 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 hier müssen wir
noch einen hochziehen zack zack und 1&1
und dann müssen wir hier wieder zur
seite rüber gehen und zwar von hier drei
blöcke 1 2 dann hier 123 und hier
zwischen müssen es jetzt fünf blöcke
seien nicht gezählt aber ein zwei drei
vier fünf jahre das passt und ich glaube
das sollten wir sogar jetzt eigentlich
ganz gut doch hinkriegen wie den
einstieg ich dachte das wäre ein
bisschen tiefer die sache ist allerdings
dass wir jetzt den weg machen werden und
dafür benötigen eine menge fichtenholz
falltüren und eine menge eichenholz
stufen das soll nämlich jetzt hier
losgehen wie ich das allerdings genau
machen werde und wie das aussehen wird
das mache ich in der nächsten folge
meine lieben freunde denn ich bin schon
wieder bei mehr als eineinhalb stunden
und möchte die heutige folge wirklich
ein bisschen kürzer halten denn heute
spielt auch köln relegation gegen kiel
also ich hoffe ihr drückt die daumen
oder haben die daumen gedrückt ich weiß
ja nicht wie es dann ausgegangen sein
wird weiß ich allerdings mal eben ganz
kurz machen kann ist meine erde nehmen
und danke hier vorne das loch eben
stopfen denn ein anderen dass in der
nächsten folge auf jeden fall nicht mehr
auf der to-do-liste also hier einmal
kurz palette voll bauen mit der erde
zack zack
es ist echt glück dass immer genau diese
stelle hier getroffen wird
hier vorne weil hier weiß ich mir nie
wieder sein so richtig war hier noch ein
bisschen
ja doch gut so beim raps ende ich weiß
nicht was genau hier so war ich glaube
hier hatten wir noch jede irgendwie so
oder nicht ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
ist ja auch egal ich glaube nie doch
hier war keine erde oder keine ahnung
ist aber auch egal
ich habe hier vorne den ball zwar
komplett abgefälscht so dass die blätter
hier erstmal weg gehen weil ich jetzt
nicht noch so einen baum ihr hinsetzen
wollte den ich dann so ein bisschen
anders frau weil der hier ist ja schon
ein bisschen anders erst ein bisschen
anders
also das wird auf jeden fall besser
aussehen in der nächsten folge damit die
komplette gras überall sein und dann
konzentrieren wir uns auch hier vorne
drauf ich weiß nicht also von hier oben
sieht es irgendwie ganz geil und mit dem
3er weg weil er dann genau so rüber geht
hier vorne zur anderen hin und auch wenn
man dann von unten hier hoch cook ist
das ganz geil weil dann guckt man hier
hoch und der weg geht genau perfekt hoch
die einzige sache die mich ein bisschen
stört ist es wenn man hier hochkommt das
dann hier plötzlich ein zweiter weg wird
aber werden eine ähnliche situation hier
vorne wo wir hier zwei blöcke breiten
den weg haben und dann wird es hier auch
einen blog breit also davon lebt ja auch
unsere welt ein bisschen das alles ein
bisschen durcheinander ist ich würde das
heute ich will jetzt alle meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat die
sonne geht unter das ist schön wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da würde mich
sehr freuen aber nicht meinen kanal
werde noch kein teil der nutzer seit und
klickt auf die glocke ist kleiner baum
wieder gewachsen
ich blickte auf die glocke wenn ihr neue
videos nicht verpassen wollte youtube
hat in letzter zeit sehr häufig probleme
meine videos freizuschalten wegen
urheberrecht oder was weiß auch ich
immer der peter pan weiß was ich bin ich
schon wieder lange zeit auf sollte eine
kürzere folge werden war es auch
hoffentlich sind übermorgen wieder 20
uhr
[Musik]